all right talk to me about bitcoin what
uh you uh i get the sense that on
breaking points like you want to keep
talking about bitcoin kind of sliding it
in there like let's get like a bitcoin
segment what are your real beliefs about
bitcoin what is it you're you're
unshackled right now you've got the
floor what do you think about bitcoin
look i'm pro bitcoin i'm absolutely pro
bitcoin i'm a little bit more skeptical
of some of the other stuff that's going
on um and we could get into that if you
want but at the end of the day i believe
and this this pandemic really taught me
and they actually made me a lot more
libertarian which was we have to have an
alternative ecosystem monetarily
financially societally media everything
in order to circumnavigate or circumvent
and go around the mainstream all the
channels and the only way that that
exists at least from what i can tell is
bitcoin the original and the
decentralized currency the hedge against
the current global financial system
because we just i just did a whole thing
about blackstone and the hedge funds i
can't be reliant ultimately on big tech
and others in order to try and protect
me i'm grateful to them for not screwing
with me yet but that's not a viable
system in the future so look it's simple
i met biology srinivasan like three
years ago um he was the first person who
ever truly red pilled me on what a
crypto future could look like and
honestly almost everything that he told
me then which i thought he was crazy
turned out to either not either be true
or is happening like right now as we
speak in terms of he was the first
person who told me about you know people
were gonna you know geographically
circle you know go around the united
states basically have regulatory
arbitrage i was like i don't know maybe
i mean you're in florida you know what i
feel like look at austin tell business
is booming san francisco is basically
dead so i think that the core of the
bitcoin future is a hedge against the
most powerful people in the country and
ultimately to me the pandemic taught me
more than ever before that we have to
have the ability to amass alternative
wealth from the mainstream in order to
use as leverage to protect our interests
and to me bitcoin remains the number one
way in order to do that i've been i've
been a hodler for like three and a half
years something like that i i won't sell
it it's not about the price uh to me
it's about the actual assurance for the
future the uh the part that's so crazy
about it is like it's a hedge against
the rich people but then the rich people
of course economic incentives take over
like oh wait people are gonna make money
i just always joke like there's no way
wall street's gonna sit by and let a
bunch of strangers on the internet make
more money than them right and so like
these idiots are gonna go they're gonna
buy bitcoin which then pushes the price
up right and it's like this whole
positive feedback loop which satoshi
ended up calling out very early on
saying listen there is this like
positive feedback loop to an asset like
this so it's fascinating to watch